says we're live
oh don't know if that's true
i'm sure i'll find out in a minute
we shall see we shall see
oh i'm seeing highs hi
lots of folks in cappuccino crafts gozer
hi carowind
cara ms wicked wolf hello jack
nice to see folks
how am i how am i
i am
just lovely
ah that'll do
ah
i'm quite nice now
here's the thing it hasn't really been a
bad day so much as it's just been
and i'm done day
that's that's just sort of where i'm at
i'm done i'm good i'm spent
hmm
oh that's good though uh
so what do we got going on in here is
that one of those guy glasses that holds
an entire bottle
uh no i should get one of those though
that was me last weekend just done yeah
the
the weekend was nice because i
vacationed with liz and um
you know we we saw friends um
we we went to um a very cool museum
in massachusetts we went to a botanical
garden
it it was nice
it was just nice and relaxed and it was
it was good to get away with her
um but of course the thing is then i had
to come back
uh nose back to the grindstone and this
has just been a day that's just had a
lot of
stuff yeah
which museums and gardens um so the
museum
you know we'll start with the gardens
first because the gardens are easier to
explain
uh the museum takes some take some uh
explaining that's very red water
no it doesn't look that way to me i
don't know why you're seeing it like
that
um so
the gardens were the smith college
botanical
gardens um which were nice there's a lot
of that
campus that's just you know you can feel
free to roam around we were gonna go to
their art gallery too but that was
closed
um had jury duty today sat in a
courtroom for nine hours and wasn't
selected yeah that
that was my jury duty too when i got
called a while back
um so and then the
uh museum
um that we went to was the eric
carle museum i'll explain that in a
second
uh yes egon nina's canon
is it though are we sure about that i
mean like
clearly we're talking about the new
ghostbusters trailer which i've
shot a reaction to i just haven't had
the time to edit it because amongst all
the other
nonsense going on today i had to watch
my
uh my mother's puppy unexpectedly for a
bit
so and and i couldn't edit because i
have to keep an eye on the puppy
but he can't come in my office there's
too much stuff to chew
so i have shot a reaction to that
trailer
have not had the chance to edit it so
that'll go up tomorrow morning
but yeah janine shows up and she
obviously has a lot of very affectionate
terms to say about egon but that doesn't
necessarily mean they ended up together
i hope it does mean that i want it to
mean that
especially because janine with lewis was
[ __ ] stupid
i'm gonna be swearing this stream i'll
try not to go nuts with it but like
that's how it's gonna be
let's just um let's just be honest about
it
so anyways eric carl museum so
eric carl you may not know the name but
you probably know his work he was a
children's book
illustrator and writer he is best known
for the very hungry caterpillar
he had a very unique art style um and he
passed away
fairly recently but there was a museum
dedicated to him and to um picture book
art in general so they have like one
gallery
um dedicated to
just eric carl's um work and then they
have
rotating um exhibits
words i i know words rotating exhibits
in the other galleries so what they had
was they had
oh god what was his name i couldn't
think of his name earlier and i felt bad
so i gotta i gotta check
this because i took i took a lot of
pictures
um it was actually brian
i wanted to say ashley brown but i'm
like it's not brown ashley brian
who did a lot of um children's books
um based around spirituals um
and and you know the history of those
kinds of songs
uh so that was that was really
fascinating
um and then what was really cool is they
had an
exhibit dedicated to
um uh
wordless picture books so picture books
with
no text no dialogue just the images
telling the stories
and a lot of these were books i'd never
heard of and just seeing like the
the selection of images from them and
like the descriptions that were posted
alongside it was fascinating some of
these
some of these bits of arts were gorgeous
and some of them
were humorous some of them were really
surreal like in a very cool way it was
really really cool that said i have
i have a hard time deciding
whether my highlight of the art car
museum
was the um wordless picture book
exhibit or
the gift shop which is not um the
consumerist
thing that it sounds like
um because like i would say
80 if not 100 of the staff working
the gift shop were um delightfully
openly queer
so i i actually conversed with them a
bit and it got started because the mask
um that i wore it's it's got
it's got pentagrams with the with the
pride colors on them
so um
they one of the one of them spotted that
and was like oh i love your mask and so
first thing i did was i wrote down for
her um
hi-ho silverworks uh website
uh so that's hiho silverworks.com check
it out yourself
because that's my friend who designed
that and it's like there's a whole other
bunch of designs on masks and shirts and
that so that was really cool because i
they brought it up like on the
on the computer and i i got to hear them
squeeze over some of the designs that
hi ho has done it was um
it was a lot of fun so yeah that was
that was a nice trip
um we went to a not-so-great mexican
restaurant but we went with good friends
so hey meg nice to see you pop in
that's always good oh people talking
about frog and toad i remember frogging
code books
only in the broadest sense i don't
remember any specifics about any of them
hi ho or hi ho h-i-h-o
uh li like you're saying hello to a hoe
hi
ho that's that and like that that's not
a
dig that they're a burlesque performer
in addition to an artist so
like that is their last name is hi ho
silver and it's the
branding they put on their uh on their
merch and their store and their
design stuff questions have you seen
avengers hero of tomorrow which is an
animated film came out in 2011
that instead of following the classic
avengers it follows the kids
no i have not heard and was not aware
so there's your very fascinating answer
to that question i tried to save a baby
bird yesterday but i was too late that
that's a shame i mean if
baby birds in general are are really
vulnerable and i've had that
that's a lesson i've learned a few times
unfortunately
i love frog and toad and adore owl at
home
arnold uh lobble rocks owl at home
those i don't think i even read i
remember reading
frog and toad
i've heard of owl at home
but i don't think i've ever ever read
that
like he wanted to say hi ho silver away
so
geek filter if you're on tick tock um
you should you should check out
um their account it's hijo silver
vibes on tick tock um
but not every time but they they
frequently start their tickets with
hey there hi there ho here and i'm just
like
oh it just makes me happy what's your
favorite animal i don't have a favorite
animal
animals are just awesome uh have you
seen any of the paddington movies
if not one to watch with the kid we saw
the first one
um she didn't like it enough to be into
uh
watching the second one so uh i think i
suggested this but have you seen
starkids works here on youtube
i've seen one star kids um piece i've
seen twisted
and actually on the com on the patreon
commission docket
is another one i'll be taking a look at
the
guy who didn't like musicals or it's
called something like that
so i'll be checking that out hopefully
next month
if i can keep up uh the pace that i'm
going at
uh vera i'll i'll read it to you
sometime
i'd be delighted uh picture books from
my childhood the snowman the tiger who
came to tea
we're going on a bear hunt and uh each
peach pear plum
oh okay so each peach pear plum um
that was one uh we read
to my kiddo um
a fair bit and um
that was that was a cute one
like i had when i was growing up i had a
fair bit of dr
seuss and then it's just a bunch of
random stuff that i don't know anyone
else
who knows it there was like um
seven frogs go to school um
there was
what was there there was um over in the
meadow was one i really liked
there was um the monster in the bathtub
like these random things that i don't
know anyone who knew these
um are you going to see the jungle
cruise movie with the rock i think
that's what it's called also has emily
blunt
and jack whitehall i would like to
um i'm not in a massive rush on that but
i would like to at some point because it
looks like it potentially
kind of has the um the vibe
of um of something like the brendan
fraser mummy
which i'm here for um
would you ever appear on the mass singer
it doesn't matter they wouldn't ask me
i'm not feminist
i'm not feminist hmm
famous enough star kids musicals of
harry potter had the best depiction of
dumbledore
uh the only one confirmed gay i've i've
heard that but like i'm not
i uh i'm not in the mood for even parody
harry potter anymore i just i can't
right now no
uh the kids and parents follow as such
jame rogers son of cap and black widow
azeri son of black panther and storm pym
the daughter of ant-man and the wasp
taurean daughter of thorpe i mean okay
it's an interesting enough gimmick
yeah sure why not why not
[Music]
um saw your
the owl house review today what do you
think of the okay i'm not gonna say out
loud what that is that you put in the
chat because that's a spoiler
what do i think of that story line i
don't really have thoughts on it because
it's not really a story line yet it is a
hint
of something that's going to be a thing
later at least it's not a storyline in
the first five episodes
which is all i've seen because that's
all that's been put onto
disney plus if had has started to become
more of an evident
thing in uh the episode since then
do not tell me i don't know when they're
going to go on disney plus
they're recap they're remaking the
exorcist what are your thoughts my
thoughts are they are not it's
officially a continuation
not a remake
i don't know why i've become a mock snob
out of nowhere
oh
you know i really do love
cranberry juice
have you read marvel voices pride and or
dc pride i
have not i've not read a lot of what dc
or marvel have put out
in a long time like very selectively
like
my relationship to the comic books
industry is not dissimilar to my
relationship with the video game
industry which is that i kind of keep a
like an eye on it but i don't actively
engage
with it so
uh try to leave off
i've only just uh i'm only
i've only just realized after recording
commentaries on
doctor who episodes how much my adhd
turns me into a verbal t
into verbal tick incarnate like here's
the thing
adhd like you will
as you come to better understand your
own brain
um you'll look back in time
and like realize all the things that
fed into this um whether they were when
you were young or like now in your life
you're like
oh i'm like that because of my
neurodivergence
that makes way more sense now like so
many of the things that you think are
just like well like i guess that's just
weird like
if you slot it in properly you realize
oh
so like a um
a good example for me is
um when i was a kid starting in grade
school
starting i think second
grade i would walk home
from school and it wasn't a short walk
it was like
three quarters of a mile um walking home
and here's the kicker getting walking
home did not get me
home any sooner than the bus would have
actually
uh it wasn't uncommon for the bus to pot
for the bus to pass me with
like a few more blocks left to go
but i did it anyway not because i was
trying to get home faster
but because i was bored out of my
flipping mind sitting around and waiting
for the bus
my brain could not tolerated it i
hated it so much just sitting there
waiting for this bus and not doing
anything
so it was more satisfying to my
at the time not yet diagnosed adhd brain
that even though it doesn't get me home
faster at least i'm
doing something i'm not just sitting
here i'm
doing a thing i can look around and the
scenery's changing
this is better it's just better
and uh yeah so that's uh
uh that's the kind of thing i mean where
you like you look back and you realize
just how
deep this [ __ ] runs
also all the heroes were killed by
ultron like from
avengers uh to the inhumans side note
this ultron is 10 times
better than the live-action version in
my opinion i don't know i
there are very few of the big villains
of both
dc and marvel who i actually find very
interesting
i don't generally find ultron that
interesting
i sometimes find thanos a little
interesting
i don't find annihilus interesting i
don't find k and i'm talking about the
comic book iterations here
i don't find kang and interesting
like really the interesting
one is
doctor doom he's interesting
um but the rest of them not not so much
really
fat bottom girls are larger than life
fat bottom girls you know
don't don't mess with queen that bottom
girls you make the rocking world go
round
[Music]
then like the bass drum kicks in ah so
good
yup zan i've got consensus in the um
in the chat on this
uh with the name that doesn't at all
telegraph he's a villain i mean
i forget the name of the phenomenon
where like your name
seems to dictate your your career path
in life like the guy's name was victor
von doom
what else was he gonna do out of all the
doctors from the modern era which one
would you most like to travel with
um for traveling i'd probably get along
best with 11.
um even though 12's my favorite
um but like i think i would annoy 12.
or at least i fear that i would
um
where did i leave i was gonna back up in
the chat i'm not gonna bother
um you know cranberry juice
um so like if you want to be sure i
catch
i catch a comment like that's what the
super chat's for the super chat also
gets you
me giving you a heart and a thanks thank
you so much shout out in your lives
your twitch live streams with me cavity
i'm not gonna do that i don't think
part of the reason i'm willing to do
that for this is i'm usually
hydrated by the end of these so
you know it's um flows off the tongue a
little bit easier
i am change so uh
twitch stream is still gonna happen at
its usual time
i am um switching up the game
because up to this point i had been
playing
hearthstone which i will no longer be
doing because
[ __ ] activision blizzard
um that is a company that should not
exist
and i hope dies i don't care how
it should not exist burn it down
and so as a result i am
um i'm going to be instead
streaming a um
dating sim visual novel which i have
tested and should run
fine uh even though i don't have a new
computer yet so
uh it'll be it'll be a nice change of
pace for those of you who do
join me uh on the twitch stream
twitch.tv slash council of geeks
um you know follow me over there also
you know here like share subscribe
i'll [ __ ] for myself sure why not
would fawn pants have a third sleeve
what you mean for the tail
or for something else
i don't think so either way
good calling that there's an employee
walk out tomorrow good
good if they could afford
to all quit i would say that they should
but i i know that they that they can't
so um
yeah like the
the video game industry right now
the worst offenses of
the capitalist system are all
on display to the nth degree in the
video game industry right now
and activision blizzard is a really good
point too
for that
so uh yeah burn it down
so magic arena i don't oh
i'd like maybe i'll check it out at some
point i
i'm i'm ready for a change up in the
kind of game i'm playing too
who's got pizza who has hawaiian pizza
what
who where waiting at the door for pizza
oh
lucky uh
hawaiian's good i had um
i had hawaiian the other day well not
yesterday two days ago that was nice
that was real nice hawaiian's great
pineapple is excellent on pizza
i don't know when the hell it became
like a thing to be like pineapple pizza
but like you're all wrong so
uh i think i'm the i feel like i'm the
only one who's starting to get sick of
sympathetic
villains and miss charismatic villains
like handsome jack from borderlands or
the joker
um i'm not
i'm not sure how much we're getting
actually sympathetic villains but
it has become more common practice to
try and bring shades of gray or to
humanize
um to some degree villains and like i do
appreciate that
um i think
uh that in general there's some really
good stories that can be done with that
but
there's a fun to
just the villain who knows they're a
villain and
loves that and like that's not even a
recent thing you can go back
to goddamn shakespeare for that you read
titus andronicus
and aaron the character of aaron who
knows he's the bad guy
he knows it two is core he knows it
and he loves every
second of it and he's a
phenomenal character you can
like you know what it's almost like
it's almost like the inverse of the
people who think
superman's uninteresting because he's so
good
and he's such a goody two-shoes that
like you have to make him
morally like dirtier to make him
interesting no
if you write him well he's still a
wonderful character
and it's the same with just a straight
out villainy
villain villain face from fillington
villencania and so is your dad so
like that can be a lot of fun that can
even be an interesting character with
depth
because it's a common saying nobody
thinks there's the
they are the villain so what does it say
about a character if they
do think they're the villain if they
think that and are still doing this that
is a question that can be interesting
for a performer to explore for an
audience to enjoy
so like you can bring depth
to a villain without having to make them
morally gray or humanized or
um you know sympathetic or whatever
it's it's just become the easy go-to i
think
to to go more that right and again
oftentimes with very good results
just you know not always what about
banana pieces on pizza
that be a pass um on that one
thank you very much uh
anyone watch thought slimes video on
superman and lois i saw that it went up
i didn't i didn't get around to that one
hi to the usual crowd hey callie
um i'm gonna try to talk to the old man
into putting some of our jalapenos on it
when it gets here
oh you're on your own on that one
uh let's see
uh what you say about the pure evil
villains is exactly how i feel about the
master
fair fair and like i say that as a lover
of missy who was
made more sympathetic but like i still
consider richard delgado to be the best
master as much as i love missy
uh i think that's why jack nicholson and
caesar romero are my favorite jokers
they were just vibing same with mark
hamill for that matter
i'm putting money on paul dano's
character being called edward nation
rather than edward enigma
that would piss me off
if that happens because like look
batman is silly
if you're too afraid of the silliness of
batman
then you shouldn't be tackling batman or
at least you shouldn't be tackling
characters and stories that lean into
the silliness of batman
if you want a silly free batman you
can't do the riddler
the riddler's very silly
that said the trailers make it look like
he's um
they're basically going to have him be
john doe from seven which
i'm not thrilled about if it ends up
panning out that way
fawns third sleeve yes why
why this is the second time you brought
it up why
what do they need a third third sleeve
for
i don't know if you're implying
something that i'm just not getting
because
uh or like i don't i don't
i don't know where you're going with
this i don't mean to be
uh cranky sorry
it's just been a day thoughts on dc
animated films
i am way behind on those
because they stopped being
consistently good they used to be very
consistently good
then they were intermittently good and
utter crap and to pull um
the description from
um cell specs and
her term uh the main offender of that
was [ __ ] bag damien
he was not the only offender but he was
the big one he kind of exemplified
why those got so bad
so bad oh my god
if you don't mind seeing me with short
hair in front of a badly done green
screen effect you can go back to some of
my old videos
on reviews of things like son of batman
and batman versus robin and
oh god they're all so bad
[ __ ] sort of atlantis was crap
too
oh
because they're enormous
so two things about that my friend
one all they have to be
is a grower not a shower and
their and and with that being the case
two if their fur on their legs is thick
enough they get by just fine without
i wouldn't put a fawn in pants what's
wrong with you any
song that has something to do with being
sexy perfectly defines you
oh thank you bonds are known to be
gifted in the groin area wink wink yeah
yeah i know that
i'm playing a fawn in dnt right now
i'm aware cara
thank you you get a heart
thank you very much i finally got my
roman order
taking bets on how long it will last
we're on three days now
also beginning to think i have adhd can
you tell
i mean like serious
um if you think you might have it
be sure you actually talk to your
primary care physician
and arrange to get diagnosed
officially because it's
there there's a lot of quirks about it
that people go like oh i do that i
wonder if i have it like
and you might you might and if you do
you'll
be appreciative for the help that they
can offer
but if you don't it's better to know
that than to start going down the rabbit
hole of thinking you have a condition
that you don't
have um
as far as taking bets if you're on three
days so far i'm gonna say
five so two more
uh i've watched all your reviews of dc
animated movies the sanity seemed to be
seemed to be being drained from you with
each one with each one film
it did get to the point where if they
were good it was kind of an amazing
surprise
like batman bad blood was pretty good
and i was shocked
by that i think the one that really
broke my enthusiasm
was how bad the killing joke was
and i honestly think i was kinder to it
at the time than i should have been
that really is a piece of
absolute garbage that movie
is such trash
and it's um
it's about half the reason why seeing
the name brian
azarello on a comic book will
immediately make me put it down and walk
away
i've no interest in reading anything
from that man
ever uh question
do you know the origins of the uh green
little bugger
uh in the background but the what the
tonberry
i mean i know what he's from because
i bought him for myself if you're
asking me if i know what the
what like the inspiration for the final
fantasy
monster that that is um is no i don't
um admit it you know you're sexy of
course i [ __ ] do
jesus christ
um good morning from germany good
morning to you as well
uh they're all trekkie
just i i um
i cannot read that last name rowan
but david something starting with a d
seems to be a lucky charm for dc the
dark knight gotham
polkadot man and suicide squad and the
voice of calendar man the longest
halloween
oh that guy uh i haven't seen the
longest halloween yet i've
really kind of put off
um like there's a ton i haven't seen at
this point i haven't seen
apocalypse war i haven't seen death of
the family
i haven't seen long halloween and like i
just
uh i don't know if i wanna
that much uh what movie are we talking
about that was trash
oh uh that was the killing joke movie
that was that was garbage
have you seen justice society world war
ii if so what uh
what you think i have not so i think
nothing uh what's your favorite song
from
six um it's
give me a second i i know what it is i'm
just
like i'm not struggling to think of what
one's my favorite i'm just
uh the wrong song has gotten stuck in my
head
all you want to do god damn
there it is
super exciting because i'm going to fan
expo boston with all the safety
precautions of course christopher
eccleston
and kevin congress are going as well as
other guests
i've been to that one before i'm not
going to i'm not doing another con
um though i say another i'm not doing
cons this year
um because i can't afford it maybe next
year
and boston would be a viable one because
it's the kind of place where like i
could do it as a as a day trip
and also i have friends within a
short driving distance so feasibly i
could possibly even crash with them
and not have to pay for a hotel um so
like come next year i
i might want to look um into
uh something like
um fan expo or possibly
um the
granite state comic con whatever the new
hampshire one is
uh if the timing lines up that's the
other thing these have to fall during
weekends when i don't have my kid
um because she won't like i i actually
think she might have fun
at a comic con but not enough fun for it
to be worth the haul
to bring her to one uh is the issue
there favorite muppet since we're just
shouting stuff out
um depends on whether or not we are
going to
count sesame street puppets as
muppets if we are then it's grover if we
aren't
i kind of incline towards sam the eagle
these days
which is weird cause as a kid i didn't
get him i didn't really get the joke of
him but
he's really funny
i'm finally returning to the cinema on
thursday night
to see edgar wright's new documentary
the sparks brothers
enjoy rowan hope it's a good time
so i have both versions of justice
league at home i still like
the whedon cup more um there are
certainly things that the wheaton cut
has that the snyder one doesn't that i
enjoy and appreciate um
i will freely admit the snyder cut is a
more
cohesive film than the than the weed and
cut was
uh
you'll be back or or all you want to do
oh forgot stop mashing
song titles together
stop trying to break my brain
let's see much much
much i haven't been to a munch in a long
time but a few years since i've been to
one of those
i wonder how many people will get what
i'm talking about when i say that
uh i thought gonzo would be your
favorite i do like gonzo a lot i think
my thing is is that about half the time
he's played
a little too melancholy for my taste
when gonzo's in his more
manic moods i dig him a lot but like he
does have these very melancholy you know
the the eyelids go
half mass or
bits and i don't care for those as much
uh oh geek filter
thank you you get a heart
my friend thank you very much sam the
eagle
at the muppet 3d ride now salute
to all nations of the world but mostly
america
yeah that's him i love it
he's really great
uh
or in um treasure island it is
the american way i mean the british way
no that wasn't my betrayer and that was
muppet christmas carol
was that where that one is from haha i
corrected it
before any of the rest of you could get
me and show me up and make me look
stupid i can make myself look stupid
without your help
thank you very much it's more cohesive
that's true but any movie that doesn't
have aquaman
sitting on the last so of truth is
automatically bad
however the alfred bruce dynamic was
better in snyder i
i did enjoy that moment too i agree with
that um
i'm not surprised you've been to munches
vera and i'm not surprised you knew what
i meant by that carowinds so fair's fair
have you seen any opera yes i've seen
mozart's the magic flute
i was in my teens when i saw that it's
pretty good
pretty good uh gonzo's bipolar maybe
maybe um let's see
what would sam the eagle be like under
the trump administration
i think uh sam the eagle would have come
out a drunk
i i think uh he
that that would have broken him
the thing about that scene is that
people have pointed out how
freaked out the boy playing young
scrooge looks
i've never noticed
huh see if i remember to watch for that
um
next time goes to look up munches
um you might have to take google safe
search off to have that be a meaningful
thing to look up
um then again maybe you shouldn't do
that
uh it's my job to break your brain yeah
well
i'm still standing but we'll go with
that
that's that's what that's uh more than
half the bottle
that's good that'll do ah
let's see any thoughts on the doctor who
series 13 teaser
uh yeah i um
not many i mean it's just like i talked
a little bit about it on the break room
of geeks and actually channel pup just
put up a
conversation that he recorded earlier
with me
and um and the who chaser
um and again i don't have a ton of
thoughts on the teaser itself it's just
it's mostly clips of the cast in little
moments and i don't get much from that i
would rather they'd have shown
monsters or settings or something are
you trying to make me look stupid in
front of the other guests you don't need
any help from me sir that's right
i don't think there's anything wrong
with with colonel mustard
frequenting a house of ill repute all
soldiers do don't they
oh please but he holds a sensitive
security post in the pentagon
and colonel you drive a very expensive
car for somebody who lives on a kernel's
pay
i don't i came into the money during the
war when i lost my mommy and daddy
what am i doing
this is this is this is all your fault
uh you know that the big reason they did
the movie was because they
could do the a fozzywig pun hey if
that's what got us that movie
i'm on board for it i feel like sam
uh would have been initially caught up
in the in mega taking it at face value
maybe briefly but like he's also an
idealist
and i think all that would have been
shattered under trump
getting drunk tonight i
i dispute that interpretation
i am partaking of cranberry juice
and let look look
it's it says
cranberry uh don't pay any attention to
the fact that
my finger was covering up the words
underneath that or a certain percentage
by volume
number it's cranberry it's cranberry
juice
sam the eagle has more self-respect and
dignity than trump well
yeah so does a dung beetle what's your
point
uh
i'll take full responsibility for that
gladly good somebody should
um i'd be more excited for series 13 if
it was
five episode the mini series format i
mean
i'll actually be
kind of surprised
if um
[Music]
if it is as much an absolute continuous
story as
chidnal has implied i expect there will
be smaller stories contained within it
all the same 25 proof
cranberry juice um
good guess
i won't take full responsibility well
fine then wild discord ah
yes yes ah thank you ah
vero that's how he wound up singing
jungle boogie oh god
sammy eagle with jungle boogie
jungle boogie jungle boogie
jungle boogie okay uh
checking the discord which as a reminder
is
a
perk it's perk
it is a perk of the um
patron supporters and is the other way
to guarantee that your questions or
comments will be read aside from super
chat
and nothing there
huh well that's
all right i'll try not to read into that
that's a first
hmm
have you seen any of my clowns one man
show not sure if it's available
on u.s amazon prime or not it's the
sweetest thing i haven't spawned that
much in a long time i did not know he
had one
i know my booze oh clearly um
let's see let's see let's see
so do you think you've had enough drinks
to give doctor in distress another watch
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you
um let's see
you cook yes a little
um not a ton um but yeah
intermittently
i i like
i like cooking for other people i tend
to i tend to get
uh bored cooking for myself if it's
something that's going to take me more
than 15 minutes uh again
adhd i i strongly suspect so i'll
if i'm cooking for myself i'm rarely
going to do anything that's going to
require a ton of prep and then go in the
oven for like 45 minutes like i'm just
not going to do it
um give me a pan i work on the i work on
the stovetop
that's that's me in cooking oh new type
jb
lee i thank you you
my friend get a heart
hello hope you're well a question do you
think mcu
will be able to portray both political
mutant metaphor
and the cosmic mystical side in
x-men i mean something like god loves
man kills might
not work in the mcu um
i for the size that the mcu
is now um it certainly would empower
them to tackle the more bonkers cosmic
mystical
um side than the fox stuff was ever
equipped to do
um you know and in the fox series
both apocalypse and um
dark phoenix looked ridiculous they were
those stories were too big for the
for what those films were up to that
point that
said those films did do the smaller
scale
um political allegory at times
excellently
so i think what i'm inclined
to say is that
um while a sto i mean like it's worth
keeping in mind that marvel
doesn't actually lift direct stories
very often for the mcu
even though they'll steal names um i
would be surprised if they tried to pull
something like god loves man kills
um as a movie if they end up doing
like here's what i tend to think from a
business perspective would be the best
way to do the x-men
is to actually have them primarily
focused as a disney plus
tv series item um because
there you keep it on a smaller scale and
you do the political stuff you do the
god loves main kills you
do the oppression allegories
um and then in the movies you do the
bigger stories you do your
apocalypse your um
brood invasion you know your um
have kitty pride lead the marauders
seriously have kitty pride leave the
marauders in
the movies please
she's a bisexual pirate queen with a pet
dragon
just please please
but maybe just maybe doctor in distress
isn't as bad as you remember
i look this doesn't make me stupid
nice try um
you need to be drunk and high at the
same time to watch doctor in distress i
don't get high anymore
i don't really want to either i have no
distinct desire to get back to that
part of my life gotta say i love to have
the death and return of superman as a tv
series
um the return definitely
because like if you're if that story's
ever gonna be done right which i would
argue it never has been
um you really it really needs space to
breathe
falcon and the winter soldier went way
harder on the politics than i expected
and it was very down to earth and
relevant yeah no
it was it did that quite well
um then ditch
crisp rat and make kitty pride star-lord
afterwards
i i don't need that much no lie let it
let kitty pry be kitty pride
let it letter let her just be awesome
because kitty pride is
awesome you got high before i'm
damn near 40 years old
yes i've done a lot
ugh do i look like a teetotaler
it seems as we're talking about muppet
christmas carol and on the subject of
paul williams's
songwriting have you seen bugsy
new i think there should be
an mcu anthology film just a bunch of
short films
call it amazing fantasy or tales of
suspense or gender
journey into mystery i think an
anthology tv series would be a
better use of that format anthology
films just
really aren't a way to go
they just aren't a thing anymore
i mean what was the last anthology film
and i'm not gonna accept the answer of
um
[Music]
uh grind house because those were two
full-length movies
crammed back to back um
i guess if i guess it would be the sin
city sequel yeah
would you ever do a burlesque number
with
one of the songs of the bakshi boys are
in sync
i mean maybe if i had a number that
would benefit from that music
so possibly
not planning to currently
oh i was thinking of the twilight zoom
movie well that's like 80s that is
vhs one was that film um
mid what are we calling them the
naughties i hate that term
the 2000s the mid-2000s
almost 40 you don't look a second over
14
500 days i am not running the math on
that
so i i don't i don't know if i've just
been complimented or insulted because
i ain't gonna do it nearly 40 hello
mommy oh
god dammit
i'm gonna have to accept my new identity
as a
milf aren't i
[ __ ]
it like to get high it's weird
i mean main thing for me was time got
very strange
i would um i would just kind of stare at
the wall
and like 20 minutes would pass and i
wouldn't realize it
or i would do what felt like
10 different things and it's been 30
seconds um
yeah i'd
it's not it's not an experience that i'm
gonna big up
especially a hot sexy milk well
a milf by definition is generally
accepted to be hot and sexy
that's what the f is there for
you either die a waifu or live long
enough to become a milf
[Laughter]
i like that i like that a lot what's it
like to skinny dip it's cold
that's that's that's what it is
um uh what did you use
what did you used to use to get hive you
don't mind us asking i um
i had um it was just
like statute of limitations is up on
this because this is like
12 years ago um
but i just it just smoked weed you know
just had a pipe
uh glass pipe called it watson
um because it kind of kind of had that
classic um
sherlock holmes in kind of shaping them
elementary um so yeah
this is that
uh night vera goodbye nod if no doctor
in distress will persuade you to watch
the star wars special it's your
trenzolor
good night ben terse nod for you
uh
let's see depends on where you skinny
dip well i live in new england
so even in the summer the water's cold
unless you're talking about a small pond
um it's the water's always cold
even in the summer
what's it like to get drunk and high at
the same time i don't know
and it's not because i never did both
it's because i don't remember
oh new type jb lee coming back in
you get a heart
looking for a heartbeat heartbeat
um also of x-men uh
would them
i love that you asked this would the
more kinky romantic tones like the
hellfire club and the whole
cyclops jean mattie aka clone of gene
drama work in the mcu
would it work yes will they do it
that is a tougher question
because the hellfire club holy
crap
here's what i would like to see as a
challenge i would like to see them
integrate the kink elements of the
hellfire club
in a way that feels less outright
exploitative of the female characters
and the female form because i absolutely
believe
it is possible to do kink need not be
degrading nor objectifying
you can bring that vibe without
necessarily having to put an established
in
in the comics at the time pretty young
like she was an adult but like young
character
in a corset and boots
that said damn that was a look
oh i'm trying to remember now if she had
a whip or a riding crop i think it was a
rioting crop
i feel like black queen later had a whip
but i think when it was jean i think it
was a
rioting crop
dwight hang on
no i was trying to remember if i still
have my writing crop downstairs or if
it's upstairs i think it's upstairs
a different drawer
tasteable kink by vera trademark that
tempting um
it's funny i've gotten more um
comfortable with just openly talking
kink and i
i'm going to partly blame farscape for
that
because talking with jesse on
the what the frel podcast and just how
horny and kinky far escape is as a
series
holy [ __ ]
like i i couldn't i couldn't let those
things go uncommented on so
yeah i've gotten more comfortable
talking about that stuff on camera
i'm assuming that aside from writing
songs for the muppets
streisand and the carpenters you mostly
know paul williams
for voicing the penguin actually what i
tend to think of first when i think of
him
was the fact that he portrayed an ape in
the
fifth and second worst
uh original series planet of the apes
film
copernicus was that his name i forget
what his character's name was
he was pretty good movie wasn't very
good though
uh i think getting drunk and high at the
same time is called getting crossed
almost it's called crossing the streams
uh don't cross the streams why it would
be bad
i'm fuzzy on the whole good bad thing
what do you mean bad
try to imagine all life as you know it
is stopping instantaneously in every
molecule
in your body exploding at the speed of
light total protonic reversal
right that's bad right important safety
tape
teep important safety tip thanks egon
ray take the left
egon take the right
like i don't know if people think i'm
joking when i say i have certain movies
memorized
but it's not a joke uh
[Music]
if you ever review glee you're gonna
hate will schuster seriously miss wiki
wolfie if you ever want me to
talk about glee commission me
pay me money
give it to me and i'll do what you ask
i'll do what you want and i might
even enjoy it we won't know until we get
there
okay so that was a thing
uh can you type jb lee again
uh thank you another heart
since you are a kitty stand thoughts on
jubilee
jubilee
at her worst
um was very try hard
and her worst was unfortunately during
her initial introduction
in the early 90s she was such a and like
um it initially
um a well-meaning
um attempt at recapturing the teenage
feel
of the x-men originally because
originally they were those characters
were young
um and even like when the series was
kind of revived in the 70s you know you
had characters like
kitty pride who were young and were kind
of the hook in
so when those characters were allowed to
age it made sense to bring in a teenager
again
to try and you know keep that uh feel
alive um with everything and to
bring it back to that sense of youth and
rebellion and
feeling um you know the world oppressing
you
as you're trying to figure out who the
hell you even are so like on paper i
totally get why they introduced jubilee
and it was a good idea unfortunately the
reality of jubilee especially when she
was first introduced is she
always read like what a board room full
of
men in their 40s 30s and 40s
thought teenage girls were interested in
and sounded like
it was painful
for a lot of that there were a handful
of times it kind of worked
but cranberry juice yes jesse
it's cranberry juice it's um
a little more than half a bottle worth
of cranberry juice
um but yet jubilee
was a good character to introduce and
concept in terms of what she was the
execution of that
was not good she was better utilized
later on
which is not atypical with comics that's
one of the actually the nice things
that's one of the benefits about a long
running series even the worst characters
can be done right with enough time and
the right writers coming back going hey
that wasn't a bad idea it was just done
badly let me try
so that is one of the nice things about
comics as a medium as an ongoing medium
jack frederick boom heart
for you how about a burlesque show to
doctor in distress
[Laughter]
you couldn't pay me enough
i'm not going to say there's no amount i
would i wouldn't do it for
but that amount you could not afford
would you look into guessing on quest
in show i'd love to hear you in season
three
i don't know what that is
so and i'm not gonna remember
like tweet at me tomorrow or something
and maybe i'll look into it
uh just finished rewatching doctor who
series eight today and really enjoyed it
what are your thoughts on it
i liked it better on a re-watch than i
did at the time but i keep in mind a big
part of that is knowing that
i really like where the doctor's going
to end up by series 10. so the first
time i saw series 8
um i didn't love it because i wasn't
connecting with him yet but then i
connected with him
in series 9 and absolutely loved him by
series 10 and really appreciated the arc
of his character
through series eight nine and ten so
going back and re-watching it
was uh was beneficial and i i did enjoy
it more
um with sort of that hindsight knowing
that yeah where it was going where it
was gonna pay off
sexy wine aunt vibes
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't mind me i am just your drunk witch
aunt
greetings batman you've taken the bait
as i knew you would now prepare to meet
your end
in my aviary of doom
in my uh big
bird house admit it you love it when i
bully you
i admit nothing you think you can break
me
you can't uh rp podcast set in a fantasy
world i can't tweet
ah the thing is i don't think
i have the spoons to take up a second
um role-playing gig
um because i've already got quill and
sword which i love doing
i don't i don't think i have the i have
neither the time nor the brain
space to um
[Music]
to to do more than one i don't think i
mean i'll check it out
just as a thing i see they're making a
gender switch to redo if she's
all that garbage concept hasn't made it
any better by changing the lead
ew what ew
why what
90s nostalgia is going to be painful and
not just because
it'll make me feel old i've been
subscribed to you for two years now
i'm sorry um i should wrap it up soon
uh we gotta start a burlesque fund me
um
i would never try to drink to drink
oh god i definitely gotta stop i would
never try to break you i just playfully
tease you
[Music]
so yes i should
i should wrap it up i'm gonna give it
like two more minutes you got any
last-minute questions you want to get in
or money you want to give me
[Music]
uh this is your chance to do so um
i'd offer you i've i'd offer to flash
you for the right price but i don't want
to get
this stream or this channel to monetize
so
that that won't be a thing
what's the first thing that comes to
mind when you see me on your live
streams
um broadway
uh not gonna lie i do not remember the
90s well
i do it was my formative years i don't
really remember the 80s
that much not the pulp not pulp
pop culture i don't remember the pop
culture of the 80s all that much outside
of a
couple of things um because like i was
too young
i wasn't paying attention really if the
price is right uh
enough the demonetization wouldn't be an
issue
um that would have to be an impressive
price
but like i look
i will say what i always say i will
never say
that i am not for sale i will only say
that i am not
cheap was born in 97
so does that make me a millennial or
part of gen z
um
i don't know i don't know where the
cutoff is
i think you're gen z but i don't know
google it uh
do i hear i remember the 70s not for me
the 80s shoulder pads and mallets best
to skip it
the shoulder pads oh my god uh
i remember the 80s and 90s mostly kids
stuff of the 80s like she-ra punky
brewster
gem and smurfs yeah i remember like that
stuff being around stuff that i actually
took in would have been
thundercats uh he-man
and the real ghostbusters uh
the chat low-key in decent proposal in
you
like look
i know my price but i'm not gonna say it
in advance
i'm just wondering if anybody will ever
meet it
how much do you think i'm worth
because you know
a sex worker will name a price and all
respect to sex workers
that's fine but i'm a lady
make me an offer
ah
can't think of another question so have
a milftastic night i
will with my
uh my within the last year developed big
mommy milkers
i cannot believe i just said that praise
out loud
oh my god someone's gonna clip that
and i'm gonna regret regret having said
it
uh ever hear of the scp foundation i
think it would be right up your alley
um
[Music]
i have i can't remember what that stands
for
um but i know i've heard that
don't know if you know but i hate the
greatest showman oh that's fine you're
allowed to be wrong
why do why does broadway come to mind
when you see me because that's
the general area of stuff you tend to
pester me about
uh what can i get for some vegan
brownies
problem with vegan brownies is they're
so oily or at least the ones i've had
what comes to mind when you picture a
broadway musical of winnie the pooh
for some reason i just immediately
purchased purchased
pictured i need to stop uh the
just um
god pooh's hole
you know in the ground with the with the
tree next to it uh or
like does he live in a tree i thought
for some reason my
my brain made it a hole no he's not a
hobbit
it's a tree he lives in a tree yes
yes does he
crap
would you like the m
would you like the mcu show to show
tensions between the x-men
and avengers like in the comics because
avengers are the cops while the x-men
are marginalized outcasts personally
not particularly because i never really
liked that storyline if i'm being
completely
honest one of the reasons why i wasn't
thrilled at the idea of disney acquiring
fox in terms of taking over the x-men is
because
in the comics x-men work the best when
they are treated in their own
bubble and sort of handled as separate
from everything else
the the stories where they are more
integrated
into the um the mcu and dealing with
things like the avengers like x-men
versus avengers
i don't think are particularly good
stories
so i'm inclined to say they're best kept
in
their own bubble not to mention i kind
of feel like
the mcu came they didn't do that exactly
but they came close enough to it at
least spiritually with
um captain america civil war it's
possible that it could work
it would not be my go-to recommendation
aside from last of the mohegans what are
your favorite daniel day lewis
lu luis
performance um
probably there will be blood but he
really is good in everything
so what do you think of the boys never
seen it
vera.exe is not working uh
buffering
oh goodness when did you first realize
you were allergic to cats
when i was a kid and had a sneezing fit
from putting my face in a
cat and cat fur so there you go
who's the evil cat and cats all of them
they are all evil they try and lure you
in
with their kindly little song and like
oh look how look how
pretty and and carefree and jellicle we
are they are
all evil they are there to steal your
soul
do not go and see cat's life no one has
gone
to see cats live and come back with
their soul intact
they take it from you piece by piece and
every time you go
you lose a little bit more people who
say they went to go see cats they say oh
i've been
five times 10 times 20 times they have
no soul left it is gone
it has all been taken from them they are
all
evil
and on that note i think we are going to
wrap it up
don't ask me what that was
i don't know i don't know
[Music]
then cat's kicking the door and drive
you away kicking and screaming that
would have been the perfect ending to
that
so thank you all for
for joining me and whatever this was
holy crap thank you so much
somebody mentioned it at the front end
of the stream yes
i do feel better for having
spent this time with you folks
thank you what's wisps gender i'm trying
to fill in a wiki
wisp's gender is not your business
those who have been fortunate enough to
be able to
join wisp in a private bedroom setting
they're the only ones who will ever know
there you go
uh don't forget to find that riding crop
i know exactly where it is so thank you
all
uh i appreciate your
company i appreciate your generosity i
appreciate your support
and what i want you to remember is that
you are beautiful you are valid
you are loved
you are the council i just run the
meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned beware of the
cats my cavity